Rachel's with us in Denver Rachel
welcome to a millionaire themed era
thank you for joining us thank you Dave
got to be on what is your net worth just
actually a little bit over three million
now awesome very cool and what's that
invested in it's invested in real estate
and 401ks IRAs the communities have
funds and watch how much how much of
it's in your 401k I'd say probably about
it ten percent about ten percent yeah
about three hundred thousand
so where's most of the three million
real estate we've got actually quite a
bit in cash the IRA and pretty much so
how much did you inherit zero and how
old are you guys I'm at up to ten fifty
seven and my husband just turned 66 okay
so throughout your working life time
what was your average household income
about 95 to 150 thousand a year but
right now we actually are earning two
hundred seventy-five thousand year with
four income sources different things
we're doing
yeah you should if you make if you have
three million dollars in assets yeah
that's right and what career field were
you guys in well I started off in
marketing but now in my IT program
manager and my husband has been in sales
the whole time marketing and sales and
IT okay and what's your degree in my
degree is actually in marketing what
about his in liberal arts English gotcha
and what was your GPA mine was actually
I worked full-time and with the school
at night but still ended up with a three
point six okay what about his about
three point two okay cool and how much
debt have you guys used in order to
build this wealth I mean we have two
homes and we paid off one home already
so just two mortgages on homes that's it
mortgages is over how many new cars have
you bought in your life well that's
interesting I've bought a lot of cars in
my life but we have five cars now all
but one to two years old in one of them
to our current one is we bought from the
dealership manager
she was using it as a demo but and
before you had the wealth how many new
cars did you buy - probably about ten
okay so you bought new car brand-new
cars a lot no no never new gonna you
know zero zero new o 0 and you have five
cars now yes very well you said you have
three million dollars good for you
that's cool
what's the most expensive pair of jeans
either one of you have ever bought
well I've purchased at high-end
consignment stores that's only where I
shop mm-hm and I'd say the most
expensive is thirty but they were
high-end so they were very nice but they
were still thirty it consignment stores
so that no one knows yes you're wearing
them might have been a $200 pair of
jeans
yes exactly what you paid 30 for right
so what is your generosity pattern
you're giving pattern looked like in
your life no Dave my generosity has been
to our synagogue and then the Diabetes
Foundation and quite frankly we give to
the Republican Party you know CH I'm
sure the American Dreams may be there
for our kids
I feel better giving it as well I don't
disagree or investing one of the two but
giving is a type of investing so I love
it good for you all right fun so what do
you attribute your ability to start with
nothing all those years ago
averaging a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollar a year income and now
you're 57 years old with three million
dollars how do you tell people how you
did that I tribute it to my parents they
were great role models they are great
role models are still living my mother
has an incredible work ethic and my
father always told me to purchase items
with cash only
so I would say a great you know intact
family really good parents but also
sacrificing I sacrificed a lot I worked
while I went to school and overall
that's what I would say but always
living the low way below your means talk
to me about the math though because a
lot of people sacrificed a lot of people
work hard they don't have three million
dollars I had the math work on this how
did you end up with three million
dollars well doing two three four
and sometimes five jobs at a time okay
my husband gets security now he also has
a full-time position I have a day job as
a IT program manager but I
we'll have a side business as a career
advisor so you know then you guys are
react accordingly there's a bunch of
this was in real estate so you throw it
to real estate hard didn't you like you
do yes yeah
okay so you've made some money on your
real estate I guess yes sir
okay alright good good so real estate is
investing and saving but a lot of hard
work and a lot of just living on less
than you make and exactly to be able to
know the cash flow both kids of ours are
in State University right now so cash
flowing that sons going to go to medical
school and we're going to cash flow that
and when you're hearing when you hear
one of these people in the political
realm say stuff about the wealthy the
wealthy the wealthy the wealthy how does
that make you feel you know it really is
disconcerting because they don't get it
and it's it's a shame because if more
people really understood that they can
do it too
versus saying you can't do it you're
just a ninety-nine percent IRR and
you're always going to be minimum wage
they kind of almost keep them down but
the true story is working hard does pay
off
sacrificing does pay off and I think the
politicians need to get on you know on
the task with the fact that there are
people doing it and they need to stop
mining yeah amen all right very cool
thanks for sharing with us Rachel I
appreciate you joining us
hey Dave thank you for all you do we
really really love it we appreciate you
very much for being part of this it's a
it's a big deal to do these millionaire
themed hours